any visit to Armenia must include an
acknowledgement of the country's tragic
history 100 years ago the Ottoman Empire
launched a wave of violence that killed
or displaced 1.5 million Armenians to
this day the genocide is a painful scar
for Armenia and the Armenian people
worldwide
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude does anyone really know in your
family how people survived or didn't I
think that I think it's touching for me
because my my grandfather recorded his
story onto a cassette and then he and we
we found it recently and you hear him
talking about what he went through in
yeah to hear that my grandparents lost
everyone that they knew and loved it a
very young age I don't I can't even
understand what it would be like to be
you know 12 which is held my grandfather
was and my grandmother was seven and
they just in you know overnight they
were they were orphans
see the names of villages villages that
were wiped out yes and the genocide
that's it which one what does it say
it's a sip Ostia C vos is the American
word for it's the pasta is the Armenian
this is your that's the village of my
family's from mm-hmm the story that my
grandpa tells and is that he came back
from the fields and his entire village
was wiped out and then he was taken in
by a Turkish family that was sympathetic
towards Armenians and he changed his
last name from obsession to Aqsa and
then when my family immigrated here they
changed their name back to them upset
soon goodbye well you know being here at
this memorial as powerful and sort of
overwhelmingly sad as it is I just keep
thinking about all the kids we've seen
on this trip yeah and how how fantastic
they are I mean they're gorgeous but
they're also funny and filled with life
they take as much as they can out of
life and I think that that's that's
definitely something in my family yeah
you're always kicking me the ass to say
just enjoy you know which I have trouble
sometimes doing yeah my cultures more
about you know your reward will come in
the next life if at all you gonna come
back here with your friends you think I
think so yeah definitely
I'd love to with friends with family I'd
love to come back you can come too
yeah I guess
you